the United Nations has stepped up its
appeal for donations to help flood
ravaged Pakistan it's now hoping to
raise 816 million dollars five times
more than its original Target the UN
says the funds are urgently needed to
assist millions of displaced people and
to prevent what it's describing as a
second wave of death caused by
water-borne disease outbreaks and
malnutrition
and his family are returning home due to
the floods they had to stay for a month
in a rescue camp
in their Village in Pakistan since
Province Waters have now receded
and it's safe to be back
but the devastating floods have left
their home in tatters the roof has been
damaged and the walls have cracks
the Water started washing in when the
floods came then we fled by boat towards
a dyke it was chaos at the time
their maker resources it will take the
family some time to make the house
habitable
about it Pakistan is reeling from the
worst flooding in its history
Millions have been displaced
but it's not only homes that need to be
rebuilt
stagnant flood water and poor sanitation
is putting Millions at risk of becoming
seriously ill
the United Nations has launched an
urgent appeal for around 800 million
dollars focused on emergency needs we're
entering the second wave of the
humanitarian crisis there are of course
huge numbers of mosquitoes carrying
Dengue carrying malaria
there are horrific skin diseases now
which are beginning to emerge the
European Union has also pledged 30
million euros in humanitarian aid but
Pakistan says the much promised help has
been slow to reach the country leaving
many people like Muhammad lashari to
slowly pick up the pieces and start all
over again on their own